hallo leute ich es wieder einmal waren
lange lange ist es her doch jetzt bin
ich zurück mit meinem tagebuch
wer teil eins und zwei noch nicht
gesehen hat der sollte sie sich jetzt
anschauen und dann wieder zurückkommen
für alle anderen viel spaß so letztes
mal war der siebte zweite und heute ist
der zehnte zweite 2005 hätten heute
waren wir mit der klasse
schlittschuhlaufen am anfang da konnte
ich es nicht und deswegen hat mich
marvin ganze zeit lüsche genannt
romantisch wie man sich aber früher
immer aufgeregt wenn man solche namen
gekriegt hat er mich heute jemand
luschen würde dann will ich einfach denn
hier machen natürlich nicht niemals den
finger zeigen ja gesagt aber dann am
ende bin ich richtig abgebüßt wenn er
richtig abgedüst aus vermisst ich habe
es ist dann hat marvin aber gucke ich
sag dir gute nacht ich weiß nicht marvin
ist doch in milch soll ich mit ihm
zusammen sein
massing wie don't know how wird unser
zweiter 2005 hatte die heute ist
valentinstag leider bin ich noch nicht
mit marvin zusammen da ist sie wohl leer
ausgegangen waren dienstag aber
vielleicht gehen wir zusammen
schlittschuhlaufen damit er sich wieder
lohnen kann oder was kein stolz diese
frau absolut nicht also ich jenny andré
und marvin na klar die alte clique
ich habe andere gefragt ob er noch so
viel
er hat gesagt er hasst sie
deine vanessa 24.2 2005 hätte du wirst
es nicht glauben aber ich mit marvin
zusammen wir sind mit marvin zusammen
haben nicht mal mitmachen will nicht mit
namen zusammen freut euch als wir
eislaufen waren und ich habe eine 5
geschrieben ich bin so traurig christoph
weiß dass mit marvin und mir und jetzt
sagt er als allen weiter ich war heute
beim handball und am anfang war es ein
bisschen
aber dann wurde es immer besser lisa
hatte natürlich kein bock das ist das
problem an geschwister nun freund hast
und ein bruder es gibt keinen der sich
mehr damit auf zieht als deine familie
doch ich und ann-christin machen sah mit
begeisterung und der lehrer sagt ich
habe einen sauberen wurf vielleicht wird
das ja noch was mit dem pokal oder
wenigstens einer medaille ich glaube ich
habe bis heute noch keinen pokal
gewonnen
ich habe videopreis zieht das dann bis
bald deine vanessa bei 95 da 2005 heißt
unser vieh zähne und ann-christin
synchron mit ein paar freunden einen
club hatte ich muss nicht mehr babys pro
nase leute pro nase
das ist ein klub ich habe mit marwin
schluss gemacht er ist einfach nicht
mein typ
ich brauch so einen wie hans kenny hat
auf irgendeiner brauner seite meine
e-mail-adresse angegeben
das ist scheiße jenny ist passiert hier
einfach zu viel zu viel auf einmal ich
muss ehrlich sein gibt eine ahnung hast
ja ich glaube die lovestory mit marvin
es nein auch nein ist nicht vorbei 19 53
2005 na also das mit den pro nase na ja
das muss ich mir noch überlegen
ich kann mich einfach nicht mehr ernst
nehmen es tut mir leid ich muss mich
noch mal testen lassen ich hab ich habe
irgendeine krankheit oder so ich finde
marvin ist ein toller freund geworden
nur wenn es darum geht dass er ruhig
sein soll na ja happy end für die
beziehung sie sind freunde geblieben ich
weiß nicht ein wenig bilden also wo ist
schon mal ganz süß oder doch wallach
wallach kenne ich auch besser aber ivo
schließlich ist dass christophs bruder
aber was soll ich
hab ja noch zeit es macht voll spaß in
der pause den jungs beim fußball zu
gucken
wusstest du eigentlich dass hermann 17
geschwister hat heftig oder und wallach
ist schon 14 jahre alt glaubt nur 13
dann bis bald ist schon 11 uhr gute
nacht also ganz kurze randnotiz niveau
ist nicht christoph bruder ist es nicht
irgendwie mit mir verwandt die haben
sich meine brüder genannt weil sie so
befreundet waren eine seite lese ich
noch das ist mir nämlich gerade echt ein
bisschen zuviel zwanzigster fünfter 2005
weißt du was
marvin hat mir heute bei www knuddels
punkt.de gesagt dass er noch in mich ist
das finde ich echt mutig von ihm aber
ist trotzdem nicht mein typ
mutig aber trotzdem nicht weil ich so
viel an chris und seinem haben heute
wallach geärgert ball fand sein name
aber gern sehen also am meisten ich und
sophie die anderen haben nur zugeguckt
einmal das wort geärgert und dann ich
hatte fast smackdown verbot weil
christoph jemanden in der schule
wehgetan hat zweck da und ich hoffe dass
wir weßling geschaut haben ich weiß ich
habe nicht so eine schöne schrift ach ja
ach ja hab ich ganz vergessen von khamis
freundin die tochter ist bei uns heute
habe ich mal nicht mit angriff gespielt
weil sie zum großmarkt gefahren ist dann
bis bald deine vanessa
ja was soll ich dazu sagen
was ist ein früh in meinem leben alles
passiere ich meine heute freue ich mich
wenn ich einmal die woche irgendwie
draußen war und früher
deswegen ist diese proteine aus anstieg
wir hätten dieses ganze chaos aus ganz
ehrlich ich brauche jetzt erst mal
alkohol bis dann tschüss
wir hoffen euch hat das video befallen
wenn ja dann abonniert doch den kanal
bis dann
nun gibt und euren abgetrennten daumen
nach oben